guys i've got a question for you is
there anything better than a tractor
well it turns out
there just might be well i think that
question has a lot of answers depending
on who you ask but we're going to
compare a tractor versus skid steer i'll
give you my take on it the pros and the
cons the strengths the weaknesses let's
go over it now and you know what to do
if you do enjoy the video please take
the time give a thumbs up leave a
comment below if you want to see more
tractor videos hit subscribe and if you
want something for your tractor for the
front end for the back end check out
guildbrooktractors.com
[Music]
okay let's talk about price first
because that is the overwhelming
consideration between these two machines
pricing is probably the most difficult
thing to try to quantify between a skid
steer and a tractor the simplest way to
sum it up is that a skid steer is going
to cost you more money than a tractor
but not just the machine itself also the
attachments now again just for a couple
of actual values this john deere 333g
behind me with the bucket on it with a
cab it's got the hvac cab so you have
heat and air conditioning it's high flow
it's pretty well decked out has about
400 hours on it now
three years old i'd probably sell that
for about seventy five thousand dollars
now my john deere 4720 that's going to
be nine years old about 800 hours on it
does have a cab with air conditioning
and heat
if i sold it with just a loader on there
i'd be at about 45 000
ballpark now that's not a perfect
comparison i'm not saying this versus
that machine in particular this is 100
horsepower skid steer
66 horsepower tractor you know there's
differences there but it's just a couple
data points for you to kind of paint a
picture now that's all about the pricing
for the base machines themselves but if
we're talking about an attachment like a
grapple what you see here something
outfitted for a good sized tractor again
66 horsepower tractor this loader will
lift over 2000 pounds this grapple here
is going to cost you close to three
thousand dollars however the grapple
that i'm using on my skid steer and it's
been the 333 g it could be the 330g even
the 324e that i had before that i'm
going to use a bigger heavier duty
grapple on here and you're going to be
more in the range of four to five
thousand dollars because these loaders
have more capacity there's more weight
behind there you have to size things
appropriately and with a bigger machine
even though
the footprint doesn't physically look
bigger it's just more weight more
hydraulic capacity so you need beefier
attachments to go along with that one
other interesting point on pricing is
going to be in general maintenance i
don't have nearly as much experience in
skid steers but my personal experience
so far is that skid steers are actually
a little bit cheaper on regular
maintenance and that's not talking about
things that may break and need repair
because i've been fortunate not to
really need any of that but i'm talking
air filters and greasing and just oil
changes and whatnot the service
intervals are much longer or more spread
out on a piece of machinery like this
versus a tractor and the reason for that
from what i've been told from people
smarter than myself is that construction
equipment like this skid steer is meant
to be operated by a full-time operator
right 40 hours a week and you're going
to rack up hours a lot quicker typically
in that kind of a situation versus a
tractor that's going to be used
maybe for some guys 10 hours a week
maybe 5 hours a week so that makes sense
for a guy in a skid steer that's working
it full time you don't want to have a
200 hour service interval like you would
on a tractor because you'd just be
changing oil all the time and so because
you have those longer intervals it means
you have less maintenance to do less oil
changes to do which i find pretty nice
one of the big differences between these
two machines is going to be how you're
using them with attachments and so while
it's pretty obvious you have your front
end loader on both of these machines
you're only going to use front end
attachments on your skid steer you have
the option to use the three point hitch
or the front end loader on a tractor now
this comes with its own set of pros and
cons and i love front end attachments i
mean who doesn't it's a lot easier to
see when you're looking forward a lot
more comfortable however there's a big
difference between sitting on a tractor
and looking forward or sitting on a skid
steer when you're sitting on a skid
steer you feel like you're just right on
top of the action you have very good
visibility to see what is going on up
here and depending on the attachment
you're using you know if it is a bucket
like i've used one of these to help
grade out and smooth a driveway or if
you're grappling to have a good idea of
how to get underneath that log or that
pile of debris you have just excellent
visibility to do so now on a tractor
while it is still nice to have a view
right down in front you have the big
engine compartment that's in the way so
you're trying to look around to either
side of that engine compartment in
between the loader arms there to see
what's going down below you simply don't
have the same kind of visibility that
you do from a skid steer now on the flip
side depending on what kind of
attachments you're using i'm going to
use a mulcher head for example if you
have that on the front end loader here
on the skid steer there's a lot of
debris that's getting chopped up mulched
up and flying around so
there's a inherent danger with something
flying back and wanting to whack the cab
door if you have a cab if you have an
open station that's a whole other
scenario which is not a good one so
between a mulcher and maybe a disc mower
there's a couple attachments i probably
wouldn't even use unless i had a cab and
except for a couple fairly uncommon
exceptions there's not anything like
that for the front end loaders of these
tractors you'll see a couple little
mowers that are out there that are
hydraulically driven but they're not
very common and they are quite a bit
further away as well the danger just
isn't there like it is in a skid steer
now on tractors of course it's standard
these days anyways to have a three-point
hitch and a rear pto now we talked about
price earlier being a lot cheaper for
attachments on a tractor versus a skid
steer and a lot of those are going to
mount to your three-point hitch whether
they're using the rear pto or not but
that could be for a tiller a land plane
it could be for a post hole auger even a
snow blower forward or rear facing and
those mowers or those mulchers that we
talked about that are kind of dangerous
to operate on a skid steer those are
going to mount on your three-point hitch
and run off of your rear pto and so no
matter what one of those options you're
going with if you're mounting them on a
three-point hitch and using it compared
to a skid steer you're gonna save some
money now there's a couple downsides
that go along with that so this is going
to be behind you so from the operator
station you need to keep an eye on it or
you want to keep an eye on it so that is
going to require you to turn around
maybe not constantly but you have to
frequently peek behind you see what's
going on we actually use some mirrors to
try to get a decent look at what's going
on there so we don't have to turn around
as often but some of these attachments
like a mulcher that you would mount on
the three-point hitch or like a
rear-facing snow blower you have to
actually drive backwards while you're
using it so you are going to have to
turn around and face kind of well be in
an awkward position there while you're
using it which is just really
uncomfortable now getting back to
visibility while you're using those
attachments we talked about kind of
being a little hard to see what's going
on up front here you got to peek left or
right
but the rest of the tractor has really
good visibility you can easily see all
around you behind you on both sides it's
easy to see what's going on in every
direction
for operator safety machine safety and
the safety of everything around you a
skid steer on the other hand has amazing
visibility with what's going on up front
i mean it's incredible you're right
there you can see everything you need to
the flip side is you have these loader
arms that are blocking the view on
either side
you can't see what the heck's behind you
fortunately i do have a camera so i can
have a pretty good idea what's behind me
but if you don't have one of those most
skid steers don't
it's almost like a truss system that
you're just hoping nobody's around you
there's nothing to run over no trees no
bushes now even with all the stuff the
backup camera the visibility up here
there's big blind spots look at this
whole section this whole back corner on
either side
i've whacked a few trees it's hard not
to sometimes and as i'm getting ready to
step out of this
there's a difference in access getting
in and out of a tractor versus a skid
steer personally we have used a skid
steer a lot with pallet forks on there
which means we have something that's
partially picked up or we're trying to
get it maneuvered to pick up and if i'm
on a tractor i can easily hop on and off
from the side and kind of shift
something around get it situated
whatever i need to on a skid steer you
have two things you can do you can have
it all the way down or you can have it
all the way up but if you have your
loader part way up you can open your
door and you're kind of trapped inside
now for the longest time that just
bothered the absolute heck out of me
thinking what if the whole system froze
up part way up and i'm just trapped in
here i can't get out of the front door
well our buddies over at western
equipment slash 24 7 parts
brent did a great video actually showing
how you take this rear window out it's
an emergency exit so you can get out if
you need to
obviously you don't want to but it's
good to have a backup option and by the
way what kind of lousy salesman would i
be if i didn't mention that 247parts.com
they are an authorized john deere dealer
they can get you any parts you need for
john deere you can save money with code
gwt you go to 247parts.com place your
order enter the code save some money
can't be found anywhere else now you can
see it's a side load or a side entry on
a tractor
if you have a cab i mean same thing if
you have an open station it's typically
going to be easier to
load up or climb in from one side than
it is the other side normally have a
joystick and oftentimes it's too high to
step up and there's no intermediate step
on a tractor
but it's just totally different than a
skid steer
there is a jcb telescope i think it's
called that is side entry which i almost
bought one of those simply because of
that fact that you could get in and out
from the side you didn't feel like you
were trapped however as one person
recently pointed out in a post i had
loaded my skid steer into my dump
trailer you know a high side dump
trailer and it just barely fit there was
like three quarters of an inch on either
side it was really tight and a guy said
man it's a good thing you didn't get
that jcb because
i would have
never got out from the side
[Music]
there's a few critical specifications
dimensions weight that are going to make
a big difference on where you store your
equipment maybe how you tow your
equipment and where you can use your
equipment now in a lot of these
scenarios i think for
most folks watching my channel the
tractor is going to come out on top
but there could be
a flip side to that as well so try to
get some perspective on
how a strength can be a weakness and
vice versa depending on your situation
all right a couple data points again
we're just using these pieces of
equipment so your numbers will most
likely vary but this john deere 333 g
weighs about 12 000 pounds that's a
chunk of weight if you compare that
to the 4720 you're at about 5 000 pounds
with the cab tractor now i can think of
a couple areas in particular where that
weight difference is going to be very
critical now the first scenario will be
if you need to tow or haul your
equipment number one you need a bigger
truck more power right and number two
you need a bigger trailer and so think
about that you have twelve thousand
pounds versus five thousand pounds so if
the gvwr is ten thousand pounds for
example you can't just haul ten thousand
pounds of weight on that trailer you
have to deduct
the trailer weight itself if you have a
spare tire on there or an equipment box
something else that's driving the weight
up take that off too but let's just say
three thousand pounds ten thousand minus
three thousand leaves you seven thousand
pounds of carrying capacity in ideal
circumstances i'm not one for pushing
the limit so deduct a little bit more to
give yourself some safety this doesn't
account for extra attachments you might
want to take along with you which of
course are going to then require a
longer trailer which are going to weigh
more than and then reduce the carrying
capacity so for a lot of folks a 10 000
pound trailer will work pretty well for
a compact tractor like this depending on
how long you need to go now something
like this 333g is going to require a
beefy trailer and so you may have seen
my pj trailer it's a gooseneck that's 15
000 pound gvwr this skid steer is too
big to haul safely on that trailer so
between adding the 333g and we also have
a manitou telehandler that is i think
it's about 16 000 pounds i had to add on
a couple extra trailers to my arsenal so
we got another gooseneck that's 24 000
gvwr and we do have a triple axel dump
trailer that is 20 000 gbwr that i've
hauled this around in and it works quite
well now maybe one small advantage to a
skid steer over a tractor is that you
can typically get by with a shorter
trailer for a skid steer than you can
with a tractor another time when weight
is really important is if you're going
to be traveling across your lawn
a skid steer is of course extremely
heavy a tractor is a lot lighter so the
footprint is typically going to be
easier on your lawn and while a track
will spread out the weight distribution
lower the psi going to work to your
advantage
when these things start turning and
shifting and swinging around they are
going to rip up a lawn in no time if you
get a wheeled skid steer you know with
tires on it like a tractor has those
things again because of how they turn
they can basically zero turn around you
can easily and quickly rip up a lawn a
tractor is typically a lot safer maybe
the four series is getting a little
large for a long if you're gonna do a
lot of repetitive use but all your
smaller tractors too the three series
the two series the one series and and
similar models from other brands are
going to be much safer on your lawn
versus something like this on the flip
side of course right more weight can
work to your advantage you know i'm big
on safety with tractors they're just
naturally a little light so you want to
have a lot of counterweight on the
backside in order to safely and
efficiently use a front end loader feel
more planted to the ground so those
extra seven thousand pounds that you
have over here that comes in pretty
handy i mean this machine is safe secure
stable efficient i can lift whatever i
want never feel like i'm maxing it out
it's actually an incredible feeling but
it's just painting a picture of the
night and day difference between these
two pieces of equipment and really along
those lines kind of the
the feeling of safety or or comfort
while you're operating there is no piece
of equipment that i feel
safer and more secure and more confident
in than in my skid steer so that feeling
of safety has resulted in me taking my
skid steer places that i would never
take my tractor and in fact we've
actually used the skid steer to create
new trailways throughout our property in
order to safely use the tractor because
we just didn't have a safe way to get
from point a to point b there's a couple
big requirement differences between
these two machines here let's take front
end loaders for example a lot of us need
to lift a certain amount of weight and
when you have to lift that weight that
number can be misinterpreted very easily
online there's so many different data
points so many different ways that they
measure that weight so i would urge you
to not push yourself up against the
limits of what you read online give
yourself some margin give yourself
twenty percent of margin you're going to
be a lot happier that you did you're
going to use your tractor a lot
differently instead of
maybe being very ginger or delicate with
it trying not to tip things over or get
it all cattywompus and and maxing it out
pushing it to the edge so for a little
fun comparison here i used to have a
john deere 324e skid steer it was 74
horsepower this is 66 horsepower on this
tractor you know it's a few horsepower
different i get that but it's fairly
close so let's run with it so this front
end loader on the john deere is gonna
lift about 2 300 pounds to full height
which is around 9 foot if we take the
rated operating capacity i'll explain
that in just a minute on the 324e you're
going to lift about 2 700 pounds to over
10 foot high so you're going to lift
about 10 percent more with the 324e and
you're going to lift it about 10 percent
higher that term rated operating
capacity or roc is something you don't
really hear in the tractor world more of
a construction equipment type of term
tied into that is called tipping load so
tipping load is
what you might think the amount of
weight it's going to take lifting up to
to tip the machine over and so on that
same machine the 324e
the tipping load is about 5400 pounds so
your rated operating capacity which is
kind of used as a safe limit to move
around with is going to be about 50 of
your tipping load so while that 10
percent difference between the two
machines didn't seem like much on the
tractor you're basically maxing it out
doing that and on the skid steer you're
about 50 percent so we talked about a 10
percent difference in lift capacity
between
the tractor and the skid steer
but the tractor basically is reaching
its tipping load to get to that number
whereas the skid steer is about 50
percent of its tipping load putting you
in a safer situation
[Music]
if you are using one of these machines
then you're using hydraulics but how you
use them what you can use them for are
going to vary greatly now we're in the
biggest end of the compact tractor
market right now so this is going to be
hydrostatic drive you can get a power
shuttle or some sort of a gear drive if
you want to you step up until the
utility tractor is a little bit bigger
and there is no more hydrostatic drive
it's all gear driven in one form or the
other but for the sake of comparison
you're going to drive a hydrostatic
transmission in this tractor when you're
operating it the same thing can be said
about the skid steer as well it is
completely hydrostatic there is no gears
that you're changing you may have a
button to push from a high to a low
range electronically but there's nothing
that you're going to be doing
to push in a clutch change direction
other than moving a handle or pushing a
foot pedal now same thing for your
loaders right both of these loaders are
going to be operated
with a joystick controlling hydraulics
to raise them and lower them to tilt
them and curl them if you have a third
function on there like with a grapple
for example to open and close the jaws
of the grapple now most of the time if
you want to run a grapple or something
that requires additional hydraulics on
your tractor you need to add on a third
function that's not going to come
standard now in my experience in owning
and operating skid steers i've never
seen one without those additional
hydraulics already on them i'm sure they
exist but they're not very common so far
pretty similar in how things are
operating between the tractor and the
skid steer but when we get to
attachments like the brush mulcher like
maybe a tiller or a mower for example
that's where there's a big difference
and that's also part of the reason why
the cost of these attachments and the
cost of the machine is a lot higher on a
skid steer you're going to have
hydraulic motors that are driving those
blades or that mulcher head or those
tines for the tiller versus a pto a rear
pto spline that's coming off the trans
axle and driving that attachment on the
back side part of the reason that these
skid steers cost so much is because of
that advanced hydraulic system that has
a lot more gpm a lot more hydraulic
power that is outputting all of those
attachments your mulchers your mowers
your rototillers your snowblowers those
all come with a hydraulic motor that's
on there which requires a large back end
system on your skid steer to operate
that so while they are extremely
effective they are also extremely costly
a tractor on the other hand is not going
to have nearly as large of a hydraulic
system
maybe 50 in the size ballpark but that's
where your rear pto or even a mid pto
depending on the tractor model comes in
handy that is a relatively cheap way to
get a lot of power you can slap a
gearbox on there you can run your mower
you can run your mulcher off the back
end you can run a snow blower off the
back end or off the front end as well
but it's a big difference because that
gearbox
is a lot cheaper the hydraulic system
isn't advanced so that's cheaper as well
i get a lot of questions about a couple
of different attachments wanting to know
from tractor owners if you can use them
on your front end loader like i do on my
skid steer the first one is going to be
that mulcher head and while it is
awesome on the skid steer it's simply
not going to work on the front end
loader of your tractor and that's for a
couple of reasons the first one they
weigh a lot they're very heavy so you're
going to eat up 50 or more of your lift
capacity the second reason is that these
tractors just simply don't have enough
continuous hydraulic flow to effectively
operate one of these mulchers the other
common example especially this time of
year as we get into winter is can i use
a snow blower on my front end loader and
the same premise applies there just
simply isn't enough hydraulic power on
one of these tractors and you will see
an option out there i've never sold one
because of the absurd price but you can
get something called a hydraulic power
pack that you actually tie into your
three-point hitch
run a hydraulic pump off of your rear
pto take some hydraulic lines all the
way up front and then have a front end
loader mounted snow blower let's just
say you could take your family to disney
world and hawaii and probably on an
around-the-world cruise for the price of
one of those setups so this wasn't meant
to be all inclusive it's just kind of
the the big things that jumped out to me
and i would love to know i think a lot
of others would too when they're trying
to make that decision right between a
tractor and a skid steer what are we
forgetting right i'm sure there's other
considerations other variables
everybody's situation is unique right
there's just a different list of
priorities that we're all going to have
now for me as we develop this 140 acres
that we have out here
i'm blessed to have both pieces of
equipment right now some of the big
heavy hitting stuff i find myself
leaning on the skid steer however i
think in the long run you know my heart
is kind of with the tractors i love them
you know for projects like mowing a
field tilling i just like a tractor a
lot better for that but there's some big
heavy duty tasks that
if you have the equipment why not use it
well that's going to wrap it up for us
today you know what if you did enjoy the
video i'd love to get a thumbs up from
you do leave a comment down below
subscribe to see more tractor videos and
if you want something for your machine
make sure you check out
goodworkstractors.com thanks again for
stopping by and until next time stay
safe we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
you